Misha and Artem Mischa Barton gets the
ballroom food in LA what does this
experience what you thought that it
would be going into it you know it's an
intense experience it was definitely
maybe more than I had bargained for the
theme of the night was most memorable
year for house star Jodie Sweetin and
her TV dad Bob Saget remembering her
dark times and getting sober I was in
cocaine to ecstasy and alcohol and all
of that
I think that's her biggest
accomplishment is that she's just
incredibly real but I teared up a little
bit talking about you and I've known Bob
since I was five years old and he's a
member of my family and it just it was
really sweet the darkest moments for me
weren't necessarily like winding up in
the hospital or anything that it was
those quiet moments alone when I just
hated the person that I'd become what
was going through your head in those
moments it's easy to sort of drown out
feelings when you're when you're amongst
a lot of noise but the quiet times are
the hardest but not anymore
you know today my quiet times are my
solace my respite and and I'm you know
have an amazing life today I remember my
mom saying that when I was little I had
this light that shined really big and
that she'd watched my light become great
dark and I just remember my mom saying
to me like your light shines again what
was that like when you heard those words
from her she said I just I watched you
come to life I watched you come to life
doing what you love and it's an amazing
thing to watch model nyle DiMarco ended
the night at the top of the leaderboard
but it was Pro Val's man-bun making
heads turn just trying to be more
relatable not a lot of people could say
they look ridiculous in front of 20
million people on live television I
can't I can't